[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROB SCHMIDT: Hi, everybody.
Welcome to our
lovely session here.
I'm very excited to talk
to you all about probably
every buzzword in the
industry we could possibly
jam into one session.
Hybrid machine learning, dev
ops, Kubernetes, Tensorflow.
Take your pick like.
We tried to fit it all in.
RYAN MCGUIRE: Bingo.
ROB SCHMIDT: We're
inclusionists here.
We like to include everything.
RYAN MCGUIRE: Everybody.
ROB SCHMIDT: Everything,
every solution, all of it
all at once.
So we'll kick things off.
We'd like to just
introduce ourselves
so you kind of know who we
are and what we're doing here.
So my name's Rob Schmidt.
I'm a Customer
Engineering Manager
for Google Cloud
based out of Chicago.
I primarily work with our
large retail customers
to help them adopt the Cloud
and transform their businesses.
And over to my left here is--
RYAN MCGUIRE: I'm Ryan Maguire.
I'm a CTO of augmented
intelligence for a Fortune 500
digital transformation
consulting company in Chicago.
We're a partner with Google.
So happy to be here.
Let Rob take the stage.
ROB SCHMIDT: All right.
So let's start with a little
bit of a definition of what
we're doing.
So what is the edge?
It's a lot of things.
It can kind of be anything
you want to define it as.
But for our purposes,
we're really
talking about areas of
constrained compute, where
you have potentially a
limited amount of resources
in which you can
execute your model.
So in data centers,
oftentimes people
are going to be
running just straight
Tensorflow on IoT devices
that sort of change things
with mobile.
There's lots of different
techniques and things
we can use, depending
on where we're going.
But the fact of the matter is
that machine learning models
are going to be running
everywhere on all
of these surfaces very soon.
So we need to start
thinking about how
we start to transform
these devices
and bring the services to them.
And we need to do that
for a number of reasons.
Obviously, with
Google Cloud, we have
lots of really
awesome Vision APIs
that are very easy
to adopt and give you
a fair amount of things.
But that comes with a cost.
So for latency
reasons, you're going
to have a round trip time
trying to get anything up
to those APIs or back.
Bandwidth is also an issue
if you're on a mobile network
or you are in an area where you
don't have a good connectivity
back to the Cloud.
Privacy reasons.
There's reasons to
do things on devices
and not ship things
up to the Cloud,
particularly with things
like, for example, like very
sensitive health care data
or sensor data or things that
are very private.
Connectivity, as we
sort of alluded to,
is always going to be an issue,
especially in IoT scenarios.
And obviously, execution costs.
A lot of times it can be quite
expensive to hurl a lot of data
and a lot of compute
up in the Cloud
to get this kind of stuff.
But the Cloud still has a role.
And we need to think about how
we leverage the Cloud for what
it's good for and how we
leverage the devices for what
they are really good for.
So to that end,
obviously, in the Cloud
you have the computing power.
Obviously we've got
GPUs and TPUs available
that you can bolt on
and use to accelerate
your machine learning processes
and get things done faster.
And that leads right
into the velocity
so you're able to move
and iterate quickly
by using things
like Cloud ML engine
and other tools like that.
The elasticity, you
scale up when you train,
and when you're done you
turn it all off so you're not
having to have
deadweight resources just
sitting out there.
Data storage is
really another area
where the Cloud
makes a lot of sense
because you have to
centralize and aggregate
a lot of this data in
order to treat your models.
And obviously training
cost is really good
if we use things
like preemptible
VMs and other things.
And on the
elasticity, we're then
able to minimize a
lot of that stuff.
So there's really
three considerations
that we need to think
about when we're
starting to think about running
a machine learning model
at the Edge.
One is the model
and binary size.
Obviously a lot of
these models are
going to be running in memory.
So if you don't have a
lot of memory, that's
something we need to
control for and make sure
we get that as small as
possible so that it's
able to run in those scenarios.
Obviously that
also has an impact
to the speed at which
it's able to run.
If you're using a lot
of the memory already,
you're not able to
push transactions
through it as fast.
And it also can impact
application performance.
And as we look at that, slow
performance in an application
is a killer.
People will not tolerate
that these days.
And you have to start thinking
about your device itself
and threading.
So by default,
Tensorflow sets that
to the default number
of cores on the device,
but we need to understand
that hardware profile so we
can decide, do we to
utilize more cores,
do we need to utilize
more threads in order
to move forward.
So that's all great.
We all understand
the problems faced.
But how do we actually go there?
And there's really four phases
that we need to think about.
And there's a lot of
constraints and considerations
that we need to
take into account
at each one of these phases
in order to get our model out.
So first we're going to talk
about building the model.
Obviously we're primarily
talking about Tensorflow here,
and the reason we're
talking about Tensorflow
is because it's a very
flexible execution environment
and training environment
for machine learning.
So we're able to
actually utilize
it to go straight from the
Cloud to the Edge with very
little change to
the actual machinery
that we're running on.
But when we can start
to consider the problem
and what we're doing,
we need to understand
where we're going to be putting
this model at the beginning.
Choices you make at
this stage of the game
have a very severe
downstream impact
if you're not considering them.
So we want to
understand where we're
going to be running this model.
Is it going to be running on
a Raspberry Pi in a closet?
Is it going to be
running directly
on a piece of machinery?
What kind of
hardware environment?
What are the
latency requirements
of this particular
model that we're
going to be trying to run?
And understand that as
we make those choices,
we're going to be constrained
in several different ways.
So whether it's the RAM or
the compute performance,
whether it's the
size of the model
or the choice of the model that
we're going to use or build,
we need to understand
at that point what
we're going to be doing so that
we can choose the right model
and build the right model.
So components at
this point, there's
a lot of different
things that we use.
Obviously Tensorflow
I talked about.
But having Jupyter
and IPython notebooks
so your team of engineers
and data scientists
can iterate quickly and share
the data and get everything
moving quickly is important.
Kubeflow if you're
in on Kubernetes,
Kubeflow is another
great pattern
that people are starting
to adopt because it kind
of homogeneous is a
lot of that training
infrastructure and
IPython notebooks
and sharing and all that stuff.
Obviously the big, glaring
hole that everybody
needs to think about is
training data and testing data.
If you don't have enough data,
there are ways around that.
But obviously we need to have
good quality data so that we're
able to actually
build this model
and get good
performance out of it.
But in some cases where
you don't have good data,
or maybe it's not
particularly good,
you can start with a
pre-trained model from TF Hub,
pull that down, and then you
can do a little bit of transfer
learning on it to
accelerate yourself and not
maybe be constrained by as
much data as you may need.
So when we look at the
actual training of the model,
first we have to make sure
we've got enough data,
as I just said.
Another constraint that
we need to think about
is how fast do we actually
need to do this training?
How often are we
changing the model?
How often are we looking at
actually improving the model,
because that has an impact, too.
If you are in an IoT use
case in manufacturing,
and you tell your plant
manager that you're
going to have to take a whole
machine down for three hours
so you can update
the sensor model,
they're not going to
be happy with you.
That's money just
flowing out the door.
Another thing to think
about at this point
is what we call quantization.
Quantization is
something that you
package into the actual training
execution in Tensorflow.
And what quantization does is
it simply takes the graph--
so Tensorflow executes in
floating point by default.
But on an Edge device or on
a very constrained area where
you don't have a
lot of GPUs, you
don't have a lot of floating
point operations, that
can be really hard to run.
It's really hard
for mobile phones
to run all that floating
point stuff at the moment.
So what quantization does
is it takes all of it
and flips it into 8-bit
integer calculation.
Now there's a
consequence to that.
So you're going to
get the performance
and you're going to get a
lot of increase and boost,
but your model is going
to be less accurate now.
So when you quantize
the model, you also
have to make sure that
you're understanding
what that accuracy
loss is going to be
and what you actually
need to be successful.
Obviously, in a lot
of various industries,
there's going to be
specialized hardware,
as we're starting to see.
We announced Edge TPUs
and things like that.
So we're starting to see some
changes to how we're actually
building these things.
And that's an important
thing to understand here
because you have to know what
you're going to be running on
so that you can actually
make sure that the execution
environment is good.
And obviously one of the
big risks to training
is always data bias.
Oftentimes we bias the
data unintentionally.
We walk in with the
best of intentions
and wind up doing it
ourselves because we're humans
and we're biased.
So understanding that you
might not have all the data,
or you might be excluding
certain kinds of data
that have an impact to your
model, is important as well.
So as we look at the
architecture of components
that we would use here,
obviously Kubeflow
can be a training and
an execution engine.
You can use the Cloud ML engine
for fully serverless style
of training and execution is
another key component, too.
And obviously using TPUs
and GPUs at this point
are really good
because it's going
to start to shrink
that time down
that you're going to need to
actually build this model out
and get it trained and tested.
So moving on to the
preparing the model phase.
So at this stage, really,
what we're trying to do
is understand that
we've got to understand
what the performance
characteristics of the model
are going to be.
A lot of ways, things
that we can do,
are built into the Tensorflow
libraries themselves.
But we want to make sure that
we understand exactly what we're
going to be doing
this model on and how
it's going to execute
in the environment
that we're going to
be running it in.
So a couple of tools
that we can use
are the Tensorflow profiler.
This is a great
built-in tool that
can give you actual
performance metrics based
on the graph that comes out
of the training session.
And then the other thing that
we start to look at this point
is the TFLite Benchmark Library.
So if you're in a mobile
or in an IoT situation,
TensorflowLite is
probably the destination
you're going to wind up at.
It's built in.
What it does is it restricts a
number of heavyweight hardcore
CPU operations from the model.
And it comes with a
custom protocol buffer
that lets you execute--
it's specifically
designed to be executed
in mobile environments.
And so what you do is, after
you quantize your model,
you're able to run this
converter called TOCO,
and that's what turns it into
the actual Tensorflow Lite
graph that you can
then take and execute.
A couple of other things
to consider at this point
are model encryption.
Obviously a lot of these
models are running in memory,
and encryption is baked into
Tensorflow or Tensorflow Lite,
but it is available to build.
There's a little tutorial
up on the Tensorflow website
if you are concerned about
people scraping the memory
and taking your model and
doing something else with it.
So that's something
that you also
want to consider at
this point as well.
At this point, now we've got to
actually get the model running.
And there's a number
of different ways
we could actually
approach this situation.
Obviously we could
run it in containers.
We could run natively
on Android or iOS,
package it right into our app.
Do we have Edge TPUs?
Are we using Android IoT?
We could have Kubeflow
deployed to an Edge location,
like, for example, if you have
a fleet of different service
centers with small data centers
inside of them, like three
or four NUCs from Intel, you
could deploy Kubeflow there.
And then you have a nice
really end-to-end service
at that point.
But you kind of need to
take into account everything
that you've got rolling
in your data centers
and where you're
going to be, and think
about how often, at
this point in time,
you're going to be
training that model.
So if you package
everything into an app
and you retrain your
model, well, guess what?
Now you've got to push the
new app out to the app store.
People got to go and
download and update it.
So there's often times you
need to think about, OK,
how am I going to do
this so that I'm giving
my users the best experience,
given the fact that I'm
probably going to be
training the model
more frequently than I'm going
to be updating the application,
because that's going to be a
key thing that happens here.
The thing about machine learning
is it doesn't really stop.
It has to keep going.
So with that, I would like to
bring Ryan back up on stage
to talk about the journey
that his team has gone through
to try to execute a very similar
vision as the one we just
talked about.
RYAN MCGUIRE: Thanks, Rob.
So we're going to talk a
little bit about an example
today, about Koko.
For those of you
who know Koko, Koko
was a gorilla who
learned sign language.
Actually, Koko was born
here in San Francisco
just down the road at the zoo.
And over a period of time,
she learned sign language,
was able to communicate.
So we're going to
use that as a model
today to demonstrate what
Rob talked about about some
of those flows.
At Solstice, our
mission is to prove
what humanity is capable of.
And what a better way to take
machine learning, computer
vision, neural networks,
and an experience
to help those in need to prove
what humanity is capable of.
So we're going to walk through
this slide a little bit
and talk about the steps that
Rob talked about, step stop
being building your
model, using the Cloud
and the power of the
Cloud to do that.
Here we had a series
of images that we
use to train the model
to make sure that we
selected the right model.
As Rob had talked about with the
deployment model of the Edge,
we want to give
consideration to the things
that we might not
have thought through.
So what operations could
go through a Tensor Lite
conversion, and how
would we do that?
Should we use an
object recognition
that's already trained, or
should we train ourselves?
Should we use SSD?
Should we use VGG?
Those types of things.
So in this phase, we
started to work out
a lot of those types of things
using the power of the Cloud
with Google Compute Engine
to do those types of things.
Really important in this
space is to have your training
set and your test
set aligned up.
So I'll show a demo
in a little bit
about using a
sparsely trained set.
We'll call her Koko Jr. She
only knows three letters.
And then we'll show kind of
a demo of Koko Senior being
trained on a full set
of data, different hand
gestures, different
colors, left and right
and those types
of things, to have
a more rich and robust model.
Once you have that model
and you've got it built,
you want to train it.
You want to set some
validation points.
Am I comfortable
at 50% accuracy?
Do I need a 90% accuracy?
How much coverage do I want?
So we'll talk a little bit
about how we did that there.
And then this whole quantize.
It's a cool word, right?
The Edge, quantize.
This is where you now get to
take the power of the Cloud
and compact it.
A whole world in a
teeny itty bitty space.
So putting it out to the Edge,
so getting ready to do that.
So we use quantization to
do that conversion down
to Tensorflow Lite.
And then we use traditional
means of CICD pipelines.
So we're constantly training
the model in the Cloud
with new imagery and
data that we have.
And we have a CICD
pipeline that we'll
demonstrate in the
application where
we're able to make the
switch between Koko Jr.
And Koko Sr. in near
real time, which
is really important to
the user experience.
Does that make sense?
Yeah?
Who wants to see Koko?
Before we do, I want
to talk a little bit
about the differences here.
So you can see the top
track, we have Koko Jr.,
who's only trained on A
and B with a minimal set
of observations.
That model is
available in a version
in our continuous
integration environment
where we can pull that down
from our storage bucket.
On the bottom, we've taking
more of a robust approach using
the power of Auto ML
engine, imagery, and data
to really train Koko Sr. To
know the soup to nuts alphabet
and interfacing with
the application.
So with that said,
we're going to bring up
Koko Jr. If you could
switch over the displays.
So here we have an Android
app displayed here on screen.
Image recognition
and cameras on.
You can see the image
process over here,
which will do motion detection
once we put up a hand signal.
But as demos go, let's
see if she's working.
Ah, she worked.
She knows A. Yay.
However, if we go to H,
which is this signal,
no letter detected.
But to prove out
that she knows B,
we can go ahead and
put up the B signal.
So she knows B,
but she's only 61%
certain that it's
a B. So now what
we're going to do is
we're going to pull down,
through the CICD pipeline that
we have available with Koko Sr.
Trained.
So we've got these buttons
that basically toggle versions
of the model back and forth
inside of the application
so that we get the
latest and greatest.
So we're going to go ahead
and update here to Koko Sr.,
and as you see, you can see,
Koko Sr. has now taken over.
But nothing's really
changed from the experience.
So we can go ahead.
OK, so she knows A. But
let's see if she knows H. O.
So you can see that
the power of having
data in a different
training set brings you
to the next level of what
you're capable of doing.
I could show you
right hand signals.
We could have a small
children's hand,
a woman's hand, a man's hand.
All of these are different
signals into your environment
when you're thinking about the
model that you're creating.
So your test inputs, your
data set are very important.
But let's envision for a
second that we took this
to the next level and we
didn't have that training set.
You could have the power
of a continuous learning
cycle with Koko that could
capture, go into training mode,
and now it's capturing images
and you're allowing your user
population to feed
back into that loop,
creating your training set.
You're not going to run
that locally at the Edge.
You want that information to
go back up into the Cloud.
And we're going to talk
about it a bit in a second.
I'm going to call
Rob back up here.
If we could switch
back the screen.
Gotta click this.
So Rob, is this how it works in
the real world today with Koko?
ROB SCHMIDT: Yeah.
But truly, that's
only half the story.
As we think about this,
at this point it's like,
congratulations, we've
deployed a model.
Like yay.
Everybody's excited.
But there's so much
more we actually
have to do at this point.
And as Ryan alluded
to, we've got
to get feedback from the users.
We've got to aggregate the data.
We've got to organize the data.
We've got to update the model.
We've got to keep going
through this cycle onward
and onward and onward.
So a couple of things that I
really liked about the approach
that Solstice took in
this model was they
decoupled the app execution
from the actual model
graph, which is pretty slick.
So they were able to
deploy that out to a CDN,
basically, and have it going
back and forth right there
without having to
update the app itself.
So putting that logic into the
application was pretty smooth.
And I think that's
a good pattern
that you're going to start to
see people adopt going forward.
RYAN MCGUIRE: Yeah.
And I think it's a
really important thing.
You talked about
something that all of us
that are intimately familiar
with, the software engineering
practices.
That cycle is never done.
You never finish an application.
You're always
constantly grooming it.
So at Solstice we've
adopted an approach called
continuous learning, which
is a mix of agile principles,
reinforced learning, supervised
learning, which we take it
through a cycle very
much like we talked
about today, and in
that prior slide,
going from selecting your
model and experimenting,
training your model, the
initial flow of that,
evaluating what are your
criteria for getting
an out the door, and
going through each one
of these steps.
But it's evergreen.
It's never stopping.
We're using modern software
engineering principles,
CICD process, maybe
some A/B testing in here
to put our model
out into production
and get our feedback.
So you can envision
an NLP chatbot
that is making a recommendation
for a particular purchase order
and asking for validation
from the end user.
Was that right?
And then that flowing
back into the process
so that we can elevate the
capability of our machine
learning models in
a commercialization
to go from just reasoning for
a human to actually helping
make decisions.
So one of the things
that we'd like to do
is just kind of walk through,
between Google and Solstice,
put together this model of what
an ideal state architecture is
and how that might fit into
a model to give you guys
the tools, as you walk away from
this conference, this meeting,
and you think about how
you're going to take forward
what you've learned here today
and apply it to your business.
So we'll start with the
Experiment and Train section.
Here, using GCP, we've
lined up the ability
to use BigQuery, Bigtable
and other Cloud storage
as kind of that
foundation data layer.
And we'll talk about layers,
how that true feedback
data flows into it.
But you can see you've got
your dev cluster and your prod
models living side by
side, creating that trained
model that's constantly
evaluating new sets of data
and new points of
data inside of that.
Anything to add there, Rob?
ROB SCHMIDT: Yeah.
I think it's an
important piece that you
need to have that I think people
don't think about as they're
going through this, is curating
your data and making sure
that you have a consistent
environment for your teams
to actually build and
experiment with these models on,
and making sure that you're
doing that in a safe way,
making sure that everybody
has access to what they need,
making sure you're respecting
user privacy and all
the other concerns that we
have in software development.
And then you give
them the opportunity
to just go right from that
spot to Cloud machine learning
and do the actual
training execution.
So you're basically
unconstraining them now
from resource usage.
And that's, I think,
the ideal states
because it's going to
let people move quickly
and actually start to execute
these patterns rapidly.
RYAN MCGUIRE: Yeah.
No, I think that's great.
And this kind of blueprint
gives a, well, where do I start
and when do I end, and
how do I start it again.
And so it's a really
good model to it.
So stepping out of that, it's
into the Evaluation and Deploy
stage.
You can take this for
what it is at this level
or you can even
go further detail.
So put in whatever
continuous integrations,
CICD tool of your
choice in this spot,
again, using that Kubeflow
deploy to the Edge,
containerizing package,
doing the TFLite,
using Spinnaker to get
it to the Edge device.
But inside of this you could
get more sophisticated.
Say you had a confusion
matrix that you wanted 90%
along your confusion matrix.
You want your ROC curve to
be these types of things
in your continuous
integration environment,
like you do today with
your web applications,
you could set a
threshold for coverage.
These models are set to have
these types of facilities
to be able to measure
the validation of it.
Your deployment here
doesn't necessarily
have to overlay the
production model that's there.
You can put that behind
an A/B testing platform.
Say 80% of your routes are
going to go to the old model
while 20% are going to
the new, so you can really
measure the value of
those types of things.
This is the type of
space where we're
taking the history of what
we've done as software engineers
and product folks and
bringing that into the model
and integrate it into
your application.
What do you think about that?
ROB SCHMIDT: Yeah.
No, it's absolutely something
I think needs to happen.
I think people need
to start taking
a lot of the things that's
painful about machine learning,
like the performance
testing, the regression
testing, figuring out what the
limits are and all that stuff,
and automate it away.
We've done that with
regular app deployment.
We need to do it in
machine learning now
because that's the thing that's
going to start to let us move
faster, and it's
also going to let
us start to put controls and
rigor around the testing.
Rather than relying on somebody
manually rigging up a test,
we're going to be able to make
it a piece of the pipeline,
and it's just going to happen.
Another thing to talk about that
this model sort of highlights
is this concept of
localized training.
And one of the things--
this is really where
Kubeflow shines,
this is the thing that
Kubeflow is awesome at.
So one of the things
that's super important
is, when we look at
the Cloud, you're
going to be training against
all of your aggregate data
out there.
But when we look at
certain scenarios
like weather forecasting--
RYAN MCGUIRE: Maybe like
rain down in Africa?
ROB SCHMIDT: Potentially.
RYAN MCGUIRE: Potentially.
ROB SCHMIDT: I'll bust the
model and then hopefully we
can get it going.
But it's important, right?
There's going to be
regional differentiation,
there's going to be
different scenarios,
there's going to be different
conditions at the Edge.
And you might want
to tune a model
at the Edge in certain
scenarios to fit this case.
So obviously I spend
my time in retail.
A very classic case of this is
demand forecasting in stores.
It's very easy to forecast
demand on an e-commerce site
because it's all coming
through one channel.
When I look at a store, a
store in California versus av
store in Florida
versus a store in Maine
versus a store in Texas, all
going to have different demand
and supply costs.
So as we start to
optimize the supply chain
and make those
predictions, we probably
want to start training on all
of our aggregate order data
across all of our
stores figure that out.
Then we deploy it locally
to the store and train
against the transaction
log that that's
coming in from everything
that everyone is buying.
And that localizes it because
we might get bad predictions
if we're looking
at the whole store
because all of our
transactions aren't necessarily
representative of what's going
on in each individual store.
RYAN MCGUIRE: Yeah.
It's that continuous
learning piece and taking
the localization factor to it.
A majority of the
models-- like we
use an object neural network for
animals that have four classes.
And that's where we
started Koko from.
And we transitioned that
to learn the alphabet.
Same type of thing in store.
You have different
parameters you
can tweak down at that level.
But the base is always the same.
ROB SCHMIDT: Yep.
Yep.
You're trained on there and
then just executing another set
of training down at the Edge.
RYAN MCGUIRE: The
last piece, I think,
is one of the most
important factors
as we think about the
maturity of models
in the commercialization space.
So how do you get a
model to be better?
How do you take it
to the next level?
How do you elevate it from
an MVP to a Version 2.0?
We like to talk about models and
AI going from an infancy state
to a reasoning state, and
then ultimately moving
to a decisioning state
so that we can augment
the human element so that we
can help the human get better
and ultimately make those
decisions on their behalf
with a high degree of certainty.
Different businesses have
different risk thresholds
and tolerances.
But in our experience we don't
see those models kind of move
forward without
taking this feedback
loop or additional data to
adjust in the marketplace.
So this is a really
important component
as you think about
your architecture
and you think about your
deployment of models,
is how are you capturing
the customer sentiment?
How are you ensuring that
what you intend to happen
is happening?
Compliance and
regulation, learning
about how did you arrive
at a particular conclusion,
and what would you do next
time when you're there?
So it's a really
important event.
And making that loop back
into the Cloud, where
you're actually feeding
that event data back
into your training set.
ROB SCHMIDT: Yeah, 100%.
And even then, this also
feeds the automation, more.
Once we build the
model and we have
that object and that artifact,
we might make tweaks to it,
we might change things for
performance reasons, lots
of little things like that.
But really, the thing we're
going to be constantly doing
is training it and training
it again and training it again
and training it again.
So if you build this
pipeline like this,
you're able to automate
all of that stuff away.
So now your high value,
hard to find, hard
to hire data scientists and
machine learning experts
are able to keep going
and working on new stuff
rather than having to continue
to maintain a model over
and over and over again by hand.
So it's very much
reflective of the changes
we've seen in the industry
to this point, especially
as we look at app
development and the way
that space has evolved over
the past five or six years,
and bringing that, now,
that same sort of rigor
and decision to
machine learning.
RYAN MCGUIRE: No, that's great.
Well, thanks for allowing
us to have that opportunity
come up here and talk to you.
Hopefully you guys have
walked away with a little bit
more insight and knowledge
as you kind OF wine
dine your time at Next.
Really appreciate it.
And if you have any questions--
ROB SCHMIDT: Yeah, we're
open for questions.
We've got about 15 or so
minutes left, it looks like.
And we're happy to take any
questions you might have.
[MUSIC PLAYING]